British actors are better at American
accents than American actors at British
you didn't even need to finish the
question I do believe that also the
British actors are far better at
American accents than American actors
are British accents yeah I've been I've
been ripped into for mine on occasion
but
um if you ask if Australians are better
at both I would go really I think in
general yeah
they're brilliant and American and
Brilliant at English I agree with that
yeah why do you think that that is
though I have a theory you go on
just the content like consumption when
you live you you consume people consume
American content constantly but not
everyone watches
um lots of people do watch down to now
be apparently the gogglebox isn't on in
the states the Google Books is where you
do your accent work from absolutely is
it no